i've been asked to do a few more
implicit differentiation problems and
this is something that i think confuses
a lot of people so
let's do a couple more problems and this
is i think there was a typo i forgot the
user that actually sent this
but i'm guessing this is what he
intended and if this isn't what he
intended this is something close so it
should give the idea so the implicit
function they gave
was
x
squared
minus
x y
plus 16
y squared
minus 400
x
minus 300
y is equal to zero
so how do we do this well we take the
derivative of both sides with respect to
x i could write the derivative operator
on both sides but i think you know that
at this point so that's the next step
so let's do that and i'll do it in blue
blue okay derivative of x squared with
respect to x is
2x
and now let's see it's going to be minus
i'm going to take the the constant term
out so minus 24
times the derivative of x y so what's
the derivative of x y we could use the
product rule here the derivative of the
first term x well that's just one right
so one is the derivative of x times the
second
expression or you could say the second
mini function or whatever
times y
and then plus
the first expression
x
times the derivative of the second
expression well what's the derivative of
y with respect to x and this is this
sometimes confuses people because it's
so easy well it's just
d y d x and instead of writing d y d x
i'm just going to write y prime here
just to get you used to a different type
of notation although i prefer d y d x
because you realize that you're using
the chain rule but anyway
x
y
prime that's d y d x
plus
so we'll do the chain rule again so
let's take the
let's take the derivative of this
expression with respect to y first so
that's just 32y
but we're taking the derivative with
respect to x so we have to take the
derivative of this with respect to y
which we did and then multiply that
times the derivative of y with respect
to x which is just d y d x or y prime
y
prime
and then this with respect to x well
that's just minus
and then what's the derivative of this
with respect to x well it's minus 300
minus 300
and then times the derivative of y with
respect to x because we're doing the
chain rule right minus 300 is just the
derivative of this with respect to y
and then once i i i want to hit this
point you know
some people when they learn they just
say oh whenever i take a derivative of y
i just take the derivative and i
multiply by y prime and that's right
that's essentially what you're doing but
i want you to understand that you're
doing the chain rule when you do that
so you're taking the derivative with
respect to y and then multiplying that
times the derivative with respect to x
which we'll write as y prime now
and all that is equal to
zero now let's simplify this so let's
see i get
x
minus
y
minus 24
x y prime
plus
y
y prime
minus
minus 300
y prime is equal to zero and let's
switch colors
so let's separate all the y prime terms
out so let's see this let's see what are
the y prime terms we have
this term
has a y prime in it
we have this term has a y prime in it
and we have this term has a y prime in
it
so we can write these let's do the
positive one first so 32y so this is the
same thing as y prime
y prime times
32y
y
minus 24x minus 24 x
minus 300
minus 300 those are all the y prime
terms and then we're left with just the
regular terms so then
plus 2x
minus 24y
minus 24y minus 400
is equal to zero i just rearranged it
and took out the y prime out of this
this and this term
let's take all of these to the other
side of the equation now essentially
what i want to do is get all the terms
that don't have the y prime on to the
right hand side and then divide by this
and then we would have solved the
equation
and let's see so we get
y prime times and this is you could also
write you know the derivative with
respect to x or d y dx
in general even though it takes more
time i like to normally write dydx
because you remember i'm taking the
derivative with respect to x y prime i
don't know you might be taking the
derivative with respect to who knows
what
so let's see
32 y
minus 24 x
minus 300
is equal to put all of these on the
right hand side so you get i'll switch
the order i like to put the positive
numbers first
24y
minus 2x
plus 400
right
and then divide both sides by this and
i'll do it in a different color because
we're almost at the answer and we get
y prime or the derivative with respect
to x is equal to this thing
y minus 2x plus 400
all of that over this thing
32 y
minus 24 x
minus 300
and let's see
we could at least it looks like well we
can everything is divisible by 2. so we
could divide the numerator and the
denominator by 2 and you get 12
y
minus x plus
over
y
minus
12 x
minus 150. and if i didn't make a
careless mistake that's the answer the
the derivative of y with respect to x at
any time is this expression that has y's
and x in it and that's cool because this
is a fairly
convoluted implicit function but we can
figure out the slope of it at any point
because we know the derivative
let's do the next one
this one is this one looks simpler x
minus y
squared
is equal to
8 y 8 times y
minus 6.
all right
so let's just take the derivative with
respect to x of both sides and i'll use
the dydx notation this time
so let's first use the chain rule let's
take the derivative of the inside so
what's the derivative of the inside
function
it is well we could do it either way
let's do the other way i always do
inside and out but let's take the
derivative of this entire expression
with respect to x minus y
well that is 2 times
x minus y
and then it's going to be that times the
derivative
of x minus y with respect to x so what's
the derivative of x minus y with respect
to x
well the derivative of x with respect to
x is just one
and what's the derivative of well we
could say minus y with respect to x well
it's just minus d y d x
you could say the derivative of y with
respect to y is where the derivative of
minus y with respect to y is minus one
and then by the chain rule multiply that
times the derivative of y with respect
to x either way i think you get the
point hopefully
so that's the derivative of the
left-hand side and that's the derivative
of the right-hand side
well we could do the chain rule or
whatever but you know this is the same
thing as 8y
minus
48 right so let's so you know this we
could write we could rewrite this as 8y
minus 48. and so
if you take the derivative of this with
respect to x this is the constant
doesn't contribute so what's the
derivative of 8y with respect to x
what's the derivative of 8y with respect
to y which is just 8
and by the chain rule times the
derivative of y 8y with respect to y
times the derivative of y with respect
to x
and now we just solve for d y d x
so let's see you get and i will do a
different color now
2 x minus 2 y
times 1 minus d y
d x
is equal to eight
d y
d
x
and then what can we do we can
distribute this out so two x
times this whole thing so 2
x minus 2 x
d y
d x
right that times that
and then that times that and then this
times this so minus 2 y and then minus
minus so plus
2y
dy
dx
and then let's take this because i want
to put all the dydx terms on the same
side so let's subtract this from both
sides of this equation so then we get
minus
eight
d y d x is equal to zero
and then the next step let's well let's
just separate out all the d y d x terms
so that's a d y d x term that's one
that's one they're easier to spot than
when you write y prime
let's see so if we take those together
and take out the
d y d x we get
d y
the derivative of y with respect to x
times let's see are any of them positive
is i'll put that one first
2y
minus 2x right that's this one
minus 8
and then
plus 2x
minus 2y
is equal to 0. let's put these onto the
right hand side of the equation
we're almost there
d y
dx
times 2y minus 2x
minus 8 is equal to
2y
minus 2x i just took those put on the
right hand side and now divide both
sides by this and we are done
d y
d x
excuse me
is equal to
2 y minus 2 x all of that over
2 y
minus 2 x minus eight and once again we
can direct divide the numerator and the
denominator by two so we're left with
y minus x
over
minus eight and we're done hopefully you
found that helpful